it's interesting to think about
a world where we don't have direct
access to reality
as hoffman argues and maybe i don't know
if you can comment
i don't know if you're familiar with ayn
rand's work and her whole philosophy of
objectivism
or her whole her whole contention is
that
you know we do have access i don't want
to misstate it but
at least she will claim that
it's not uh useful
or i think you'll probably say it's not
correct to argue that we don't have
access to reality
we have the hence objectivism we have
direct access to reality
that's the only thing we can reason
about
and the only way to live life morally is
to reason through everything starting
with the axioms of reality which we do
have direct access to right
you have thoughts about her work i am
slightly ashamed to say i have not read
ayn rand yet
so she is high on my list and she's been
recommended a number
of times um but so i don't know a lot
specifically about her philosophy or
objectivism but i
to me it resonates closely with
what the american pragmatist commented
on truth
and they distinguished what you could
say is absolute
truth which is at the bottom of reality
whether it's you know mr wolfram's
mathematical formulas or value whatever
it may be it's something
ineffable something beyond uh the reach
of epistemology perhaps even
and maybe that's why religion just sort
of points to it right it's trying to use
i think joseph campbell said something
like
religion is
using stories to point towards the same
transcendental mystery we all
experience but cannot articulate so
something like
the artist the artist uses lies to point
to the truth
something like that that kind of thing
um
that's really good but the american
pragmatist said that
because at the end of the day this is
all about when we say truth
we need something that is socially
uh close to social consensus and is not
shakeable
by political action so that's what you
know physics and mathematics are it's
it's a an unshakable
um point of reference i guess you might
say so
the american pragmatist defined truth
as the end of inquiry
and in markets we could say that
the market itself is a forum that
generates truth we call this pragmatic
truth to separate
pure objective truth that we can't even
talk about without polluting it
versus pragmatic truth which is
something that's useful so the the
example here would be
if i give you a map and you're trying to
go
from your house to the local brisket
restaurant
and the map gets you from your house the
brisket restaurant
is that because the map is true or is
that because the map is useful
right they're very hard to disentangle
just when you're looking at it
pragmatically
and in markets markets i argue generate
three forms of pragmatic truth
one is the price so this is
the collective subjective demand
and purchasing power of humanity running
up against
the objective supply of capital and
resources in the marketplace
so there's demand overlaid on supply the
result of that is the price
so that is the the tr most truthful
exchange ratio which is the closest
approximation to the value
of any good in the marketplace so it
gives us a data point on which we can
operate it's compressing
all known market realities down into a
single actionable number
you know based on the price of bread or
copper whether you want to buy more of
it
you want to abstain from buying it or
maybe you want to try and find
substitutes
and it's you can think of that price
signal it's like an economic nerve
signal that's coordinating human action
across time so if we're one
socioeconomic
super organism or collective that the
price signal is the nerve
and that's the first form of pragmatic
truth that markets generate
the second form would be tools and
innovations themselves
so entrepreneurs are experimenting
across time they're trying to satisfy
the wants of consumers consumers are
sovereign in the marketplace
whatever the consumer wants the consumer
gets right i'm trying to satisfy that
i'm trying to do it at a profit
so i'm trying to take viewing the
existing price signals of goods in the
marketplace i'm trying to assemble those
in a way
at a cost lower than the final solution
i'm
delivering to my customer i'm selling it
at a price higher than the productive
factors i combine to create it
and in that pro that iterative process
we're constantly
discovering new and better way better
ways of solving problems or satisfying
wants
so we could say to go out and dig a hole
right someone wants a hole dug
that a shovel is going to let you do it
much faster per hour
than you would with your bare hands so
what is the pragmatic truth of digging
holes
it's a shovel right it's the it's the
best way we know how to solve any
particular problem
based on uh the existing treasury of
knowledge
so every tool again we're back to ideas
being fundamental the shovel itself
is just a knowledge structure we've
figured out a way to create this
particular implement and then we've
indexed
the raw materials we found in nature to
this knowledge structure
to create a shovel which allows us to
better satisfy
human wants you know faster cheaper
better
effectively i'm trying to generalize
you're blowing my mind a little bit here
i'm trying to generalize the idea of
tool to how to think about it because i
keep
i keep just when you say tool i keep
imagining different
like specific instantiations of a tool
i'm trying to see
so the price is a pragmatic truth
that's uh communicating value in
this network subjective demands against
objective supply subjective so it's it's
an economic
democracy got it so that's the demand
supply
and then the tools are the ways of
extracting
uh or solving problems is the more
general kind of
or satisfying wants satisfying wants
so wants are somehow that's the
that's part of the supply and the demand
and wants are back to value right
because everything someone wants are
expressing their value
okay yeah so the shovel is a pragmatic
truth
the shovel is truth it feels like a good
book title
okay sorry so uh what what other
pregnant what is that and then the third
one
i would argue is virtue actually
oh wow and another another way to maybe
think about this is competitive
competency but it's also cooperative
competency
so we're learning over time what
characteristics
what patterns of action what mindsets
what mental tools what heuristics are
most useful
to satisfying customer wants so i think
that
becomes over time becomes sharpened into
virtue right like we know
it's best to be honest because if you
lie
it's very energy and efficient right
you're creating this little fork of
reality
and then if someone else asks you about
that lie again you have to put another
layer of lies on top of it where if you
just tell the truth you're just
recollecting what happened
and so that sort of keeps um
again when we're talking about delaying
volatility right if you lie
you're delaying short-term volatility
but you're increasing long-term
volatility what about murder i haven't
been able to figure
out why murder is bad because i just
keep wanting to murder people
and i've i've murdered many someone for
that
well that's why i'm trying to get an
interview with vladimir putin so
that's fascinating virtue in this market
with the supplies and demands and
there's the tools which is also
pragmatic truth
and there's virtue it's a pragmatic
truth
yeah and if we interfere with that free
market process
again if we overstep which just maybe
ties into murder if you
start to be coercive against life
liberty or property
so if you're forcibly taking someone's
life you're breaking down the trust
in that market that generates these
pragmatic truths
if you forcibly infringe on someone's
liberty right
for any reason other than them
originally breaking
uh or infringing upon life liberty or
property then that's not going to work
either
and then if you take if you violate
private property rights if you steal
property from others
you're breaking down the trust that
that the inter-subjective fabric
of money and markets and the rule of law
all of these useful fictions
are meant to preserve you're you're
corrupting it and breaking it down
it's kind of interesting to think about
the market as um helping evolve
the virtues it's sharpened into virtues
and then these virtues can then go on to
motivational posters
or like in books that we all agree on
yeah
and then eventually take for granted as
if they were somehow fundamental to
human nature
but they're they're not perhaps
fundamental they're just pragmatic
truths
yeah it's um but another way to consider
competition itself
is that it is a discovery process so
you know entrepreneurs are competing
with one another and they're trying to
best
satisfy consumer wants at the lowest
possible price
so they're placing bets of time energy
and capital on themselves on their their
idea their business plan
and then the market decides right the
collect the consensus of market actors
decide which one was better
one lives one dies so
competition itself is helping us get
closer to truth to pragmatic truth
so we're discovering what is the right
price for this asset
and that price by the way is derived
again
in the sense of data compression
everyone in the world can see that price
everyone in the world can then put their
skin in the game by choosing to buy or
sell or short or go long or
do any number of financial actions on
that price
and that information is then propagated
back out to everyone else
so it's this feedback loop between
market actor
and price that makes it um so useful
and and that's what carries us
it's so it's these collisions of
interest that carry us
it removes the unuseful
aspects of ourselves or of our tools or
of a price
and reveals pragmatic truth to us
you